hey I'm not a name dropping wow okay so
I went over your face right at the party
at the estate the the embassy all these
I don't follow basketball so there's all
these big time basketball players that
was there that was the place I met
LeBron and I saw Draymond in the corner
on his seat but I had my own section
with my boys but then I was talking to
all these other basketball players
afterwards but I noticed the difference
and they're so taller than me but it's
different when the fighters and the
thing because look regardless of the end
of the day I can kick your ass and butt
[__] it yeah
if I wanted to but shout out to what
month are we in a month yeah
[Laughter]
this is our this is our pride month oh
[__] leave it miles yeah yeah there's a
different energy when you walk in
there's a different respect that's a bad
man right there exactly LeBron looking
at you like he knows you can [__] him up
who LeBron that's different like LeBron
was so at the house it was only when
there's certain people when they move
around everyone just kind of like also
all the cloud trousers outside bro no
they ship them in because um I think it
was his name white kill Osiris he's like
yo
trade bringer like 400 [__] to the
house I was like oh word I don't know
who curates all this stuff sure I
haven't been talking about this 400. we
know there's women at Drake's house
there's [__] at the OVO party I think
it's like they all park at this venue
yeah and then they get [__] what is the
venue is it like
they just put a light on top of blood
they're part of this like they get I
don't know who curates it it's a good
system they meet at like a parking lot
they parked there and then again the
buses and the buses drive to the estate
or the embassy exactly you can't let any
yeah
everybody means to this thing and then
we'll take it because so we pulled up to
the house right and then we're getting
clearance and while we're in our in our
Sprinter I see this van pull up to the
house and it was like you know those
clown cars when like clowns
[Music]
[Laughter]
it's him and LeBron at the house that
was like that but LeBron was cool
because he didn't have to say what's up
but he saw me he's like yo pulled up and
we talked for like a minute what was
cool and it was just like I just I don't
follow basketball but I follow greatness
some people are full on just like yo
you're great at what you do yep so
talking to him was yeah it was a cool
moment I think the reason why it's so
easy to give it up for a fighter is
because there's no ego involved for a
not fighter how so
I know you can [__] me up so I could
just say you're great but for a
basketball player to basketball player
it's like bust your ass one-on-one
there's still like a little bit maybe
for an actor an actor or comedian
comedian a Musician musician like
fighter hotels I've been yeah I know you
see how fighter fighter goes it's like
almost a fight every single time
sometimes it breaks out like that but
yeah but the difference is even me I
can't wait to go to SPS I really SPS
what is uh when are they bringing out
the is it me and Alex should be on there
nominations me and Alex best fighter of
the fighter of the year yeah we should
be on that oh yeah because Alex don't do
what he does in Vegas when they'll go to
the ESPYs that next week Dapper up and I
bet you the same thing walk the red
carpet I just know when we pull up it's
just like oh there's them boys
get some jobs
my name is